one of the things that Vladimir Putin is
doing right now that is just like total
villain dictator Vibes is he's making a
list his list of all of the people that
he deems foreign agents a foreign agent
used to be any person who received money
from other countries then after the war
started he changed the foreign agent
list to be anyone who receives influence
from other countries which like how do
you define influence however you want
this list is now just a list of anyone
that Putin doesn't like these people now
have to disclose that they are foreign
agents at the front of all of their
videos on all of their tweets on
anything that they do they have to say I
am a foreign agent it's a great way to
stigmatize yourself from getting ad
revenue or to doing anything in Russia
and it's a great way for Vladimir Putin
to silence his critics Russia is
becoming a fascist State and that is
very sad for the people living there I
talked to a bunch of them dozens of them
in fact for a story that we did on
YouTubers in Russia journalists in
Russia incredible story told by these
voices over on my YouTube channel okay
bye